in the opening scene we are introduced
to Sam a musician residing in Paris he
pays a visit to his ex-girlfriend Fanny
with the intention of retrieving some
music tapes that he left in her
possession on that particular day Fannie
is hosting a lively gathering at her
place filled with numerous guests Sam
who doesn't seem to be interested in the
party directly approaches Fannie and
asks her to return his tapes however she
is preoccupied with attending to her
guests so she asks him to wait for a
short while as a result Sam sits alone
on the couch indulging in a few drinks
after waiting for 10 minutes he grows
increasingly impatient and once again
approaches Fanny this time he says that
he will retrieve his stuff by himself he
only wants the location she finally
tells him that the tapes are in the
office room at the far end of the
hallway Finney then instructs him to
wait there saying she will join him soon
as Sam makes his way towards the office
room he accidentally collides with a
party-goer which hurts his nose still he
enters the room and begins his search
for his belongings in the midst of this
his nose starts to bleed prompting him
to lock the door and rest until fenny
arrives not long after a mysterious
commotion breaks out just outside the
office door but Sam remains oblivious
and continues sleeping he awakens the
following morning and proceeds to leave
with his belongings but as soon as he
steps out of the room he is shocked by a
completely chaotic and disheveled
apartment bloodstains Mar the walls and
he finds no signs of anyone inside he
slowly Ventures into the stairway only
to discover that some people including
his ex-girlfriend have been transformed
into z words when he calls out to her by
name they suddenly react by charging at
him startled he locks himself inside
Fanny's apartment and tries to
understand what's going on just then Sam
notices a family trying to run away from
an adjacent apartment however they are
easily overwhelmed and killed by the
hundreds of zombies lurking outside
witnessing this a traumatized Sam
realizes that he cannot leave the
confines of the apartment so he begins
renovating the room as he is cleaning
the blood-stained floor he is suddenly
jolted by the sound of a gunshot causing
the floor to shatter peering through the
resulting hole Sam discovers that an
elderly man has ended it all intrigued
and determined to investigate further
Sam enlarges the hole using a pipe and
descends to the lower level there he
discovers a harrowing scene a resident
has committed the unthinkable after
murdering his infected wife whom he had
restrained in a chair Sam then gathers
all the essential supplies including
food and the deceased man's shotgun to
ensure his safety after this Sam
cautiously navigates the building and
closes the doors to prevent more zombies
from infiltrating he meticulously
searches each room collecting useful
items and marking the occupied ones
infested with the undead while
inspecting the premises Sam plans to
return to Fanny's floor via the elevator
but he discovers a zombified old man
inside despite this he refrains from
killing him thinking that the zombie is
harmless why would he think instead Sam
secures the elevator door with a belt
preventing the zombie from exiting after
thoroughly checking the entire building
Sam concludes that the apartment
situated several stories above the
ground is the only secure place
available following this we get to know
that the zombies have taken over all of
Paris they are very fast moving and
respond in hordes to any sight or sound
the Eerie Silence of the zombies and
lack of any significant noise adds to
the atmosphere of dread that night Sam
seeks Solas and listening to his past
recordings providing a temporary respite
from the tension as the following day
Dawns Sam keenly observes the movements
of the zombies that have overrun the
surrounding area he then calculates the
necessary quantity of Food Supplies to
sustain himself throughout the ongoing
Invasion later overwhelmed by pent-up
emotions he unleashes his feelings by
blaring music at maximum volume unaware
that it can attract the creatures
[__] idiot over time Sam's routine
revolves around activities such as
playing music exercising and shooting
the the zombies with a paintball gun
however one day he detects a putrid
smell coming from the floor beneath his
room upon investigation he comes across
a couple of decomposed corpses initially
planning to dispose of the bodies by
tossing them off the balcony he has a
change of heart and instead opts to pack
them into a bag and place them back in
their bed he simply seals the hole in
the door so that no more stench Escapes
in the next scene while taking a shower
Sam is caught off guard when the water
supply is suddenly cut off this compels
him to find alternative sources of water
as a result he arranges containers bowls
buckets and mugs on the rooftop to
collect rainwater during the night Sam
experiences a disturbing dream in which
zombies invade his room and attempt to
bite him which startles him awake as the
days pass Sam's isolation intensifies
plunging him into a state of desperation
desperate for companionship he often has
a one-sided conversation with the
zombified man in the elevator whom he
calls Alfred one day while practicing
his shooting skills Sam notices a stray
cat wandering aimlessly amidst the
undead desperate for a friend he quickly
rushes downstairs in an attempt to
capture it he offers food to catch its
attention but the cat instead walks away
prompting Sam to pursue it even in the
apocalypse cats are [__] in the
process some zombies spot him and
swiftly attack but fortunately Sam
manages to narrowly escape back into the
building shutting the door in the nick
of time he also manages to make it back
to the apartment but he is so Furious
that he shoots at the cat from the
window the recent encounter causes Sam
to sustain a leg injury fearing a
potential zombie bite he anxiously
examines his face in front of a mirror
thinking whether he should commit the
unthinkable in a harrowing moment he
nearly blows himself up when he falls
asleep with the shotgun beneath his head
fortunately upon waking Sam realizes
with immense relief that the wound is
merely a minor scratch prompting him to
burst into laughter like a maniac
several months pass and with winter
approaching Sam grapples with the lack
of heating to keep himself warm he
improvises a fireplace boils water and
takes a hot bath the weight of
loneliness gradually overwhelms him
causing his mental well-being to
deteriorate seeking Solace he turns to
alcohol and even vents his frustrations
at the old zombie Alfred you son of a
[__] Alfred one day Sam notices that
the streets are largely empty without
any signs of humans or zombies curious
about the extent of their distance he
tests it by loudly playing a drum set
the sound serves as a magnet luring
hordes of Undead back to the area who
even attempted to climb onto the
apartment's balcony by piling on top of
one another an enraged Sam vents his
frustration by continuing to play
despite the danger this isn't World War
Z after all they can't climb that high
later at night Sam awakens to the sound
of movement outside his bedroom door
reacting swiftly he grabs his shotgun
and fires in the direction of the noise
as he walks out to check he shockingly
discovers that he has shot a woman who
is a fellow Survivor overwhelmed with
guilt he quickly carries her to his bed
and attempts to save her since she is
the first uninfected person he has met
Sam carefully removes the bullets
applies medication and provides her with
a place to rest later on he notices the
woman's bag which contains an abundance
of rope and a grappling hook it turns
out that she utilizes these items to
travel between rooftops in her journey
the following morning brings relief to
Sam as he observes the woman's steady
recovery they engage in conversation and
she introduces herself as Sarah as they
share their experiences Sarah reveals
that she has met other survivors who
have managed to endure the pandemic in a
manner similar to Sam regardless many of
them have suffered mental breakdowns and
descended into madness Sam also shares
his daily routine and tells her how he
has survived thus far in addition he
introduces Sarah to Alfred explaining
that they have been together since the
beginning however Sarah expresses
concerns about the risks of keeping a
zombie in close proximity as they pose a
constant threat not Alfred says Sam he's
chill in the passing days Sam and Sarah
develop a close Bond participating in
uplifting activities such as singing and
sharing meals during the evenings Sam as
usual chats with Alfred sharing his
innermost thoughts in the morning he
calculates the food supplies for the two
of them and realizes that it will not
last for long as a result he descends to
the lowest apartment in the building
containing zombified occupants he drills
a hole in the door and shoots all the
zombies from a safe distance before
venturing inside to retrieve the food
Provisions however when he returns to
his apartment he doesn't find Sarah
anywhere and begins to panic after
searching for a while Sam finally finds
her on the roof Sarah states that she
wants to leave saying that it is
impossible to survive in this building
for long she argues that if they stay
here they will never know if there's any
other safe place beyond this apocalypse
therefore she chooses to depart rather
than endure an uncertain future within
the same confines Sam tries to persuade
her to stay but Sarah appears Resolute
in her decision this makes him angry and
he curses at her in response Sarah
simply says that if he doesn't leave he
will either succumb to death or Madness
shortly after their heated argument Sam
feels remorseful and decides to
apologize to Sarah for his hurtful words
but Upon returning to his room he
discovers her lying down lifeless in the
bed here it is revealed that his
conversations and entire encounter with
Sarah were mere hallucinations in truth
she never regained Consciousness after
he accidentally shot her that fateful
night accepting the harsh reality Sam
Mourns her loss pays tribute to her and
respectfully covers her body with a
white sheet after this he goes through
Sarah's backpack and finds a camera
containing precious pictures of her
family seeing these pictures Sam learns
that Sarah was a married woman and a
loving mother evoking further emotions
within him in the aftermath of these
events Sam decides to take Sarah's
advice even though she never gave him in
that advice he's just batshit insane but
it's good advice nonetheless and hence
makes preparations to leave the building
before that he burns all his recording
tapes bidding farewell to the remnants
of his past he then releases Alfred who
wanders into a nearby apartment that Sam
secures by locking him inside however
the act of burning the tapes triggers a
fire alarm attracting the attention of
the horde of zombies outside the blaring
sound causes the Relentless Undead to
break down the doors and flood the
building although Sam manages to
eliminate a few with his weapon their
overwhelming numbers force him to lock
himself inside at the elevator with no
options left he climbs the Elevator
Shaft and descends to the Upper Floor
one zombie relentlessly pursues him but
Sam manages to incapacitate it by
hitting it with a blunt object after
this he climbs up through the same hole
he had made earlier the place is
swarming with deadly zombies but
thankfully a thick layer of smoke
prevents them from detecting Sam who
stealthily manages to slip away in the
final scene Sam reaches the rooftop and
throws a rope towards the adjacent
building unfortunately when he swings
across the street he collides with the
wall and loses Consciousness while
hanging in midair a few moments later he
regains Consciousness and then summons
all of his strengths to pull himself up
onto the rooftop Sam then stares out
into the seemingly endless skyline of
Paris and vows to continue moving
forward nurturing a flicker of Hope for
the existence of other survivors
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching